welcome back to las vegas now so have
you ever heard of reptile dysfunction no
well if the magic dragon has the answer
in his first ever comedy special via
youtube so let's welcome pif the magic
dragon star of the show and
and mr pickles
mr piffles we just met he's really he
was really sweet yeah
hi there you go welcome looks so cute
he's the real talent you understand he's
the real i just carried the dog he he
actually is the one that tells the jokes
no he's a dog still
he just does magic tricks okay get shot
out of a cannon every night okay that
sort of stuff wow
so calm
how do you get him to be so calm
he's uh barely been conscious the last
six years been piffing the magic dragon
yeah exactly
all right now i hear that you call
yourself the loser of america's got
talent but a winner on the strip
yes so let's talk about the show and
what people can expect mr pilvers and i
were on america's got talent in 2015
and i shot pillows out of a cannon at
the end of the season finale went down
in flames but the next day
i got my own show at the flamingo the
next day the next day and then last year
we took over the donny marie showroom
from donna marie and we've been playing
five nights a week ever since wow that
is incredible what a story and and
people have compared you to larry david
the famous larry david saying that you
are the larry david dressed in a dragon
suits
doing tricks on stage apparently people
think i'm grumpy it's crazy look at this
thing who could be grumpy in a dragon
suit mr piffles exactly what's it like
being compared to such a another legend
oh i love larry david if everybody wants
to do a collab i'm up for it oh
okay you heard it here first i'm las
vegas now fifth the magic dragon and
larry david
all right i like that i like that now
you have a new comedy special yeah you
know and what inspired that coming on
the stage to the screen well we did we
took the old show that we used to do in
the smaller room in the little personal
dragon theater we filmed it we did some
stuff on the street and we thought hey
be great to put this out for the fans so
that way people can come and see the
show in las vegas and have a brand new
experience okay so what was the what is
the definition you know let's get
serious let's talk about your condition
here right reptile dysfunction
it's uh the
thing that all lizards
suffer from okay sadly it's a resting
grumpy face oh
so that's why people think it's your
condition exactly that's why people
think you're great there's nothing i can
do about it wow there's no cure
okay okay but you can make a joke and
make people laugh so does that help you
in your condition uh helps you pay my
bills
all right so let's see something like
what are you gonna what are you gonna be
doing on stage or on the screen in the
comedy special all right let's do a
little money
by the way you've got a little hair on
your shoulder you want me to
i'll get him for you there we go he says
he's sorry oh okay i was like wait a
minute wait a minute he's for you oh he
goes up down here into the pocket
watch we're taking we saw him in half we
get too tada thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you take this one
okay squeeze we're going to make them
change places snap snap open your hands
they've changed places
all right i'll try again i'm going to
take in your other hand this time okay
then squeeze blow
two bunnies
rocky look i'll get them rocky this time
both hands both hands where are you
going to catch a baby okay put that down
rocky look at this now you're going to
catch a baby
imagine the baby was falling okay
perfect squeeze squeeze squeeze squeeze
squeeze both hands both hands do you
know what happens if you put rabbits in
a warm dark place
they die it's okay we can bring them
back
blow rocky
very slowly open
oh rocky
did you all see that
okay yeah i have so many questions i
have so many
goes to explore channel eight um tell
everybody how they can catch your
youtube show they just go to youtube.com
bye mr pimples
i love you
the magic youtube.com he's never coming
back oh what what would you do without
mr piffles
what without mr what would you do
without mr piffles quit show business
forever oh okay somebody get mr piffles
and that was the last we ever saw of him
oh my gosh okay you can also catch your
show fit the magic dragon at the
flamingo thursdays through monday 7 p.m
wow we got to get mr piffles back
somebody go get them jillian often to
you i have someone over here who might
want to go